any hope that images of ukrainian
suffering
or that global repudiation of russia's
invasion might change the course of the
war is vanishing after speaking with
russian president vladimir putin for 90
minutes french president emmanuel macron
believes the worst is yet to come that
putin wants control of all of ukraine
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov
says russia will continue the war to the
end
a solution will be found is how he put
it
and while the misery in ukraine deepens
millions of russians are reaping the
hardships from a war they've been
dragged into
foreign air travel slashed shipping
deliveries cut off
and ordinary russians lining up for
rubles that are losing value by the day
everything is bad obviously she says
price is going up i don't like it
they should end the war says this woman
almost anywhere in the world now it's
not easy being russian the yachts of
oligarchs have been seized this one in
germany star athletes like alexander
ovechkin called out if they don't
condemn vladimir putin well he's
my president
but how i said like i'm not in politics
like i'm an athlete many russians are in
limbo it's my biggest passion it's my
life
vlad cheriubl is a top mountain biker a
russian who lives in canada the
governing body for cycling okayed
russians competing as neutral athletes
but he says it's still up in the air
just because i have a russian passport
basically i don't think it's fair on the
way
but i see why there is such a strong
measurements against it
if it's awkward for russians living
abroad it is life-altering for those at
home simple demonstrations against the
war have brought mass arrests and
threats of forced military service
mothers with their children reportedly
detained after laying flowers at the
ukrainian embassy in moscow
it's very embarrassing
for all of us kremlin advisor andrei
kortunov has broken ranks denouncing the
war and telling sky news life will be
tough for russians all russians will be
in a difficult position and the russian
people will feel the brunt of being an
international outcast as their country
destroys its neighbor erik sorensen
global news ottawa